في استطلاع لنيويورك
وجد انه في عام 2022 ادخرت النساء في
المتوسط
31646 دولارا فقط سنويا مقابل 7000 دولار
وفرها الرجال فلماذا تدخر النساء اقل من
الرجال احد اكبر الاسباب انها تكسب اموالا
اقل للادخار وفقا لبيانات لبيانات عام
2021 من مكتب الاحصاء الامريكي فقد حصلت
النساء في المتوسط على
84% مما يكسبه الرجال بعد تحليل متوسط
الاجور للوظائف بدوام كامل ايضا تدفع
النساء ثمنا اكبر ليصبحنا امهات اذا
تعرضنا لضربه كبيره في دخلهن بعد انجاب
الاطفال وهذا ما يعرف باسم ضريبه الامومه
فيما لا يقدم العديد من اصحاب العمل اجازه
امومه مدفوعه الاجر كذلك كثير من النساء
يغادرن سوق العمل باكرا لرعايه اطفالهن ما
يعني انهن خرجنا من حساب نظام التقاعد
الذي يشترط كسب الدخل للمساهمه لاحقا في
الدخل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات